act of moral anesthesia the groups of
all took a party in programs organized
by Germans the Holocaust shows that it
is possible to exterminate all nations
multi-perspective Ian's climbed that the
anti-polish action of old Cooper was a
part of plan historian representing this
trend they'd this action to the years
9043 45 emphatic that it took police
only in valyna and Easter Ganesha the
events in sprint 1944 in eastern Russia
sneh they consider to be a guerrilla war
during which both sides to similar
degree moderate civilians those always
emphasize that in the years 1945 47 on
the territory of present problem there
was not stop thinking like only polish
Ukrainian conflict instead three actors
play it play it in this own oppa
Ukrainian underground Polish
independence underground and communists
they believe now in the conflict 22 only
two sides is a famous take they are they
all agree about the estimated number of
casualties in the years 90 4337 about
80,000 poles were killer killed half of
them near half of them in villania and
twenty twenty-five thousand Ukrainians
were killed by poles there is a
discussion among among multi-perspective
gasps from the goals videos sorry 30
Jesus that means
hmm ok then I had to cut I will go to
that to the next next group it means to
multi multi perspective to mono
perspective eons and what can I catch
okay shamash co is a person who is a
typical typical mono or perspective
perspective young does this made made by
shamash go about the his-and-her cases
are that mmm oh it was the mass murder
of poles were a clear liga na cidade
goal and polish on Appa on Paul's sorry
ash according the shamash girl this
action was a carefully prepared
conscious leading to be illogical
extermination of Polish nation action
according to many prospective ians of
Polish nationality a gazelle began in
September igniting of 1939 and lost 47
and according to them doesn't matter who
was killed was a victim of this genocide
it means acha soldiers who died in the
battle or secret police members or
militia members after the war they agree
with multi-perspective ians about the
victims of the conflict it means 80,000
of course were killed and sound 20 25
Ukrainians the research of mana
perspective trend a clanger during the
Second World War the disappearance of
patient occurring in territorial was so
huge there was no
place for a for agreement and they rock
on the Vics visto action fully fully
favorably according to their opinion the
state well-being is a priori priority
under that human rights as a result and
of course a proof of using a collective
responsibility next group this
non-scientific Trent Prowse format and
virtual mr. Novik was talking about this
group then i will i am going to talk
only about to non-scientists who are of
who are Ukrainians fast is a police job
he he holds a special place about a
monkey no scientist as a Ukrainian and
pathologist who lives to speak
scientifically in the problem of
Ukrainian nationalism is in mmm he is
sometimes sometimes of people think he's
a little credible person to the poll
Europe to the Polish rider he tries to
place himself in the position of good
Ukrainian good